hi there its senior editor Kevin van Ord
standing in for reviewer Josiah and
Auden to tell you about Sniper Elite 3
in Sniper Elite 3 there's a guilty
satisfaction that comes from the game's
glorious slow-motion kills what the game
does best is on full display early on
and that's the grotesque and brutal
x-ray vision assassinations the level
design in Sniper Elite 3 is more open
than previous games in the series often
encouraging shots being fired for more
than 300 metres away each of the 8
locations in the campaign presents you
with a sniping sandbox where creativity
leads to better shooting and stronger
positioning rushing headfirst into enemy
territory is always an option but you're
likely to crumpled into the dirt after
just a couple of well-placed shots from
your enemies whenever you aren't sniping
sniper elite 3 can prove frustrating not
because the surrounding mechanics are
broken or the levels are poorly
constructed it's because every action
building up to you actually pulling the
trigger feels more like a chore than an
interesting setup for the perfect shot
I'll have to shoot from this side of the
canyon you're often faced with tedious
stealth sections littered with soldiers
who perk up as soon as you fire off a
noisy round clearing the map with a
silenced pistol or a knife as often the
best route to success that's not to say
that Sniper Elite 3 is overly
challenging however if you take the time
to spot and tag enemies before firing
you ensure that you have time to
relocate to another vantage point
immediately after taking your shot the
game rewards you for relocating
successfully though it's too easy to
simply backpedal to an area that you've
already cleared and then wait for
enemies to cool off too many situations
throughout the campaign encourage
close-range monotony over the wildly
entertaining sniping
you're not required to kill everything
with a heartbeat in order to progress
but the satisfaction that comes with
long-range marksmanship is almost too
great to pass up after locating a viable
target you have the option of steadying
your breath and adding a reticle that
shows you exactly where your bullet will
drop once you fire off that perfect shot
the camera follows it around as it
leisurely approaches its mark in that
very moment all that matters is the
journey of a single bullet
finale of the shot is primal bliss eyes
pop lungs burst and testicles rupture as
you pump round after round into the
opposition it's the feature attraction
of the series and it's better than ever
you kill hundreds of unsuspecting
enemies in this manner watching as
formerly distinctive faces are violently
torn beyond recognition
a handful of difficulty settings extends
the life of an otherwise stunted
campaign which features one of the most
forgettable world war two stories in
recent memory the deadly serious
dialogue hardly matches the over-the-top
kills so you can safely ignore the story
that's an officer yet on violence stuff
he has the key I'll be back for better
commentary bring a friend in to campaign
missions with some backup it can be
cumbersome to coordinate shots without
alerting the guards but adding a second
sniper to the mix creates a whole new
set of tactics to consider there's also
an asymmetrical co-op mode called
overwatch which revolves around spotting
and downing as many enemies as possible
but this is much less interesting than
the tactical challenges of working
through the campaign together
competitive multiplayer is light on
surprise and heavy on disheartening
deaths of course to discover this aspect
of online play you have to get into a
game most of the time however you just
end up disconnecting after spawning
failing to connect or crashing to the
PlayStation Force dashboard Sniper Elite
3 s multiplayer is mostly broken it's
almost too easy to forget all of sniper
threes head-scratching issues when that
bullet makes contact with someone's
cranium though it's a shallow crude
pleasure but the delightful disorder
that's just around every corner is
strong enough to overshadow an otherwise
forgettable experience
you